what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today
we're gonna watch the next episode of
snl
and no i do not mean what that
new york political candidate got caught
doing i make
jokes that are universal i'm talking
about superman and lois today
episode something or another which one
is 11. yeah very excited check this out
it's a very
underrated series guys today's video is
sponsored by greg and john go
to greg.com to get yourself ten percent
off of all
greg products when you use promo code
junk
[Laughter]
oh yeah we got patreon whoever you watch
alongs
are over there you sync over the time
code reaction highlights and watch long
sleeve for many shows at the same tier
and of course hit that like button
subscribe and
thank you tuber thumb jindal for editing
these highlights down for us you've been
killing it buddy
love you thumbs killing it buddy so sexy
you're so
killing it you're killing people
listening right you're slaughtering the
whole village
you're doing good you know how you do
all that while edit
probably be faster if you didn't do this
[Music]
no no no it's the american way
hell yeah dude he looks so polished in
that snow
yeah it's not freezing at all
that flannel is is enough
oh my god clark
can you imagine if it wasn't clark crew
founders
i mean he wouldn't just walk it around
who dares to enter
[Laughter]
leave this hallowed place gives me such
joy to see you here you are my
son the earth's
sun your cells absorb its radiation in
ways
humans cannot
[Music]
i will teach you how to use that power
super fast running effects have gotten a
lot better lately
of course that was well done i thought
possible
on this earth he's running in that same
shirt
that's what he came out of his super
suit always
for good luck but there is something
else you need to learn
first time he flew what is it why you
wish to help them
reconnect with the world find out why
you
wish to be their champion sounds like
there's a bit of disdain in his words
yeah why you won't fight for that why
don't you want to stay at the fortress
of solitude
[Music]
did you find what you were looking for
yeah i found out who i really am
i know why i can do the things i can do
mom i know
why i was sent to earth
there's someone i need to see first lana
oh is this whole thing gonna be origins
harry potter and friday night lights
it's the big flashback episode
hi hey there's an opening at the fire
station
yeah it's amazing
you've heard about a guy named morgan
edge oh my god someday i hope to be just
like
[Laughter]
oh
glasses will hide you from the world
they will fool
any even a complex facial detection
system
even the human eye from a foot away
couldn't tell
what is this that's right they said she
made it yeah that's great
gregory smith directed this one oh
excuse me start excuse me do you know
where millage avenue is
i love a good retro suit episode right
back to the first episode
that's awesome
[Music]
this kid got two paychecks
collecting them royalties
yeah that's a great looking suit i wish
they still kept it
cool costume thanks my mom made it for
me
hey you did it
some guy just saved a kid from getting
killed by a car and then he flew up
into the sky flew you know like a bird
or a plane or whatever
it was crazy you know
someone had the planet that's gonna care
about this
i could get a job taking pictures of
superman
i could get a job writing not about
superman
stick with lane she'll show you the
ropes yeah the scene too elaine
sir who told you to wear a tie
shot this on a different day
[Laughter]
mystery man strikes again third time
this month
where was he saved the boat sinking off
hops river ever since he showed up he's
been dominating the conversation
metropolis has so many problems here
look at this these lightning bolts
a rash of arson attacks against
minority-owned businesses
how can i help
oh he actually helped as a reporter yeah
this is what i've been waiting for
oh the real beginning of their love was
investigating together
this is so neat i love this
[Music]
series get all the glory he's just doing
oh that's awesome he's just living a
life guys
you're really good at this thanks
i should get going what's the hurry you
got a big date
no no you know some seinfeld reruns feed
us some frozen chicken nuggets yeah
i don't know that episode you've been a
really good help clark if you want i can
probably talk to perry about you getting
a beat of your own
um no that's it's okay oh
yeah you would be oh
yes i feel like that's a
trick question all right
good night clark good night
oop i dropped my stapler
[Music]
you can't do this henry they've done
nothing wrong
this isn't track and field kent
a great shot oh my god
i'm the damn hero
very heroic
[Laughter]
[Music]
even you can't save all of them ah
yeah you knew it yeah again
oh you go catch it
oh yeah that'll who's the hero now
that'll rattle your can
what did martha make that suit out of i
know it was like it's a fire retardant
at the very
least how'd you know about this what the
hell
we haven't formally met him lois lane
and you are who
exactly mr metropolis oh i'm sure you'll
come up with something
who was that superman
welcome to the daily planet today i'm
lois lane and with me for his first
on-camera interview
is oh oh wow
what would you say to the people of the
world when asked what you stand for
i'd like to think everything good and
decent truth justice
the american way yeah it's a bird it's a
plane
[Music]
cut i think superman is into you
yeah i am not interested okay i'm in
love with someone else
clarky clark oh
we know
that's great lois hey
random superman question he wouldn't
happen to have super hearing
i really love a clark who recognizes him
yeah i do
i appreciate them keeping it up but but
this yes the one rule we accept about
this universe hi
oh i'm so glad you could make it
oh look at you does she still not know
yet
i guess the sense i get yeah well come
on inside i've got lunch waiting
this is so sweet i want to show you
something
[Music]
oh my god he never took his glasses off
around her the entire time
not during intimacy not in the shower
oh hell yeah hell yeah
oh hell yeah
[Music]
this might be a weird time to say it but
i can't wait to tell my dad about the
wedding
he's gonna be so excited
you can go faster than that clark
lois looked beautiful i wish he could
have been there i need you to get out of
here now son
father what's happening
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was
my nipples are chilly there's something
i need to tell you
lois what day is it i'm pregnant
deprived
we're gonna be parents okay lois
something really strange happened right
now
no these aren't just flashbacks no
no oh my
is everything okay yes it's just more
okay
they are huge what are you sure
yeah god i didn't remember like exactly
what happened at the end of the last
episode when he went to went to the
fortress right
clark i'm not delivering the babies at
the fortress
something he must yeah be in some kind
of weird memory limbo
we're gonna catch him maybe it's like
time full of memories there is none more
special than becoming a father
what have you done easy color i'd hate
for you to miss the big moment
we're doing great we're almost there
damn it tyler durden
no no please please they're just babies
how little you know me brother i would
never harm a newborn
teenage boys on the other hand
that's a different matter entirely oh
[ __ ]
all hope is not lost because you're
awake carlo
now you and i can discuss the terms of
your surrender
oh damn morgan got the edge
i can't let you do this then i will make
you suffer
oh
[Music]
damn it
ah
oh no
yeah all my life i dreamt of having a
brother
a family only to have you rejected
ah it didn't have to be this way
[Music]
crap i feel bad for morgan nature
he's understandable i don't root for him
[Laughter]
but you can sympathize sarah i i'm so
sorry i i didn't tell you everything
that was happening john even wanted me
to tell you
and i i said no i was really scared
oh you too
i don't want to be just friends anymore
oh
me neither
oh they're lab partners now
show her your lasers yeah laser anyone
who disrespects her
say you're sorry kyle say you're sorry
listen i just i want to apologize to you
for the way i've treated you this whole
time you're good people lois and i'm
real happy you're part of this town
oh thank you oh don't die kyle
please don't die don't kill him in the
next scene
or secretly body swap him again please
don't do it
it's not bad oh yeah your father won't
be returning anytime
soon which is why uncle morgan decided
to come pay a video oh god
he's such a loaded lie now this is the
live
carl church even more disappointing up
close
leave now jordan stop
oh i see your sons inherited your false
bravado
this is all you're doing it was your
influence that made him turn his back on
his own people
oh no oh but i will let them live long
enough
to watch you die
oh impressive carlo struggling superhero
land
i'll see whatever you ask no
just leave my family alone pledge to me
that you will submit and i promise to
let them live unharmed
clerk please don't do that no oh god
no take a good look at the man you knew
because it will be your last i'm sorry
i needed more time he was right
oh my god my home
oh gotta admire the storytelling
knew exactly where to throw his
oh this is gonna have like a pool and
everything
my son oh oh no the first lesson
is the measure of pain it's application
being a tool of great strategic value
oh yeah
that's the way to teach somebody son of
jorah he has vowed his submission father
and be eradicated taken from his
possession
oh what are you planning clark
oh man
oh she calling a dod
john it's happening oh
i think superman's been turned
oh so
despairing
oh wow
oh not not any episode of the show has
left me feeling that way
no oh god i was so
i was like i'm in a nightmare right now
yeah
it really brings so much love to my life
it rips your heart
[Laughter]
oh yeah wow that was bleak as hell
now here i always think you're just
watching some cute-ass origin tale
no that becomes suspicious now anytime
they show us too much
touching lovely backstory you know
something messed up is on the way so i'm
a [ __ ]
some [ __ ]
good tv what is like morgan edge's
father like
oh great guy what's that cal doing no
you do in the deserts we must be
opposite from him in every way
he's got the the sign of hope we'll turn
it sideways then
anything we can do i know he chose the
desert and i know he landed amongst the
brits and that's how he was raised
just jokes all right these jokes aren't
canon
alright guys so in between
finishing the reaction and shooting this
review there's some major technical
difficulties that have
very much stressed me out so
on the span of like 10 to 15 minutes
but we're pros we don't
vent our problems to you guys copyright
claims blocks damn it
people complaining in the comments
malfunctions in the studio it's hot
outside
no there's some [ __ ] but uh you know
let's get refocused here and talk about
the episode
well i don't give a [ __ ] you know why
because the damn
computer had a problem that's the whole
takeaway
episode is i don't care anymore and i
hate superman i would like the episode
better if our equipment hadn't had
issues
it's my only complaint about the episode
i don't know why they decided to include
that for the most youtubers wouldn't
tell you guys all this stuff so
i'm gonna tell you um but yeah as far as
this episode goes uh did not leave me in
the best spirits
you know it's not supposed to broke my
heart
in the beginning when we were like
seeing the beginning of the origins
of clark this is cute this is awesome i
mean it looks
great beautifully stunning as
always there was a part of me that was
like
i don't know why we're looking at those
do i really need to see
like when he specifically when he like
first you know raises the fortress of
solitude and
and all that i'm like i like seeing this
i'm like how much focus are we putting
on this and then as it
progressed and i was like oh this is
cool okay
all right we're seeing the first time he
was really flying and then we're also
seeing uh you know how he got involved
in the daily planet and it felt
very rich or donner-esque uh the whole
vibe it was like a good blend of richard
donner's superman
meets and richard archerman classic
superman meets what they've done
here you know like there were some good
tongue-in-cheek moments some very good
nostalgic stuff
like i'm all for truth justice in the
uh the american way it's like a bird or
a plane like a flying you know
like that's what flying is i don't know
how they they try to make it sound like
subtle
but it was incredibly charming and it
just kept
it it swept me up in the in the wonder
and then
and this like sense of nostalgia without
being it's like nostalgic in the sense
that we know the superman origin story
and we know like
how the plot will go that he will work
at the daily planet superman will become
the
savior metropolis he will marry lois
lane
like we know where it's going but all
the all the new scenes especially like i
liked how it tied into the first episode
like showing you the scenes around the
montage that beautiful montage at the
beginning of the first episode
and then uh all the new stuff like how
it became very much about
lois and clark and how their true
relationship really began and it had
nothing to do with being interested in
superman
uh how it was all just about clark kent
like she had no interest in him
at all and i loved that i i really did
you know because
that scene obviously when he is being
interviewed makes you think
about the fir especially for me made me
think about the first richard donner
movie
where uh lois lane interviews superman
and she's like
clearly attracted to him and the joke
about the underwear and all that stuff
like it was a it's a classic scene it's
a really good scene too that that old
one
and then here i loved how she had no
interest in him and was only about
who is like so basically she was really
in love with clark
really in love with the man underneath
the superman persona
she's really in love with him and and
that just hit me in the field
so much and i thought that was so cool
and beautiful and the show really asks
you to
as much more grounded it gets and
uh it's execution and tone it's still
really uh
still has to suspend disbelief with the
whole glasses thing a lot yeah
that's the biggest one i mean because
they really
show you that that is his disguise you
know
it's something you he's
have done something and he doesn't
really behave too different you know
he's still like really charming as
superman he's just clumsier as clark
now this criticism it's one of those
weird things where you give it a pass
because it's just a big joke about
superman in general that's the
that's the joke about superman glasses
on glasses off
it's been that way since way before this
show
uh whereas you know at least in the
richard donner movie there was
uh what they did with christopher reeves
there was a difference in the way he
behaved you still have to stretch it
the way he like just overall comes
across one is like
clumsy nerd and then superman is truth
heroes
you know it's got to be enough that your
mind fills in the blank of like i
couldn't be clark though
you know like just because of his
mannerisms and who he is and yeah like
this clark is
he's pretty fit already he's pretty
capable he's pretty like
a good guy he doesn't even seem like
cowardly or anything like that in the
sort of
clark persona to like offset the
superman-ness
the glasses thing will throw me off
though because because i'm going
you're the greatest investigative
reporter in the world though lois
you should see it yeah all right i know
99 of people will get a pass and
and and yeah overall i'm giving it a
pass
100 000 i'm giving it a pass
although there is a thing that creates a
tad bit of a barrier that makes me go
that that just pulls me out every time
especially uh within the context here
i'm like you dated this guy and you
didn't know
you fell in love with this man and and
you didn't
yeah even have an inkling or a suspicion
you guys made love you didn't take his
glasses you ever take his class i know
it's like
you've never seen him in the shower or
anything like that or in any item like
any situation
all you then you must have caught him
without his glasses once
yeah if she if you're taking him if she
if he's taking her
to meet his mother they're in a pretty
serious relationship by this point
absolutely you'd imagine so it's
it's more funny to be it is a criticism
it's weird it's a criticism i feel
at the same time and i'm not just trying
to people please here at the same time
it is something that
because this is just something i've
grown up with with the
the whole meme essentially about
superman
you can still go yeah that's the
superman thing though you know
yeah it's weird how that works you can
criticize it but then it's so easy to
just go like yeah yeah
it's the super it's part of the dna at
some point all right
yeah one it's in the charm there of the
fact that you have to
just this you know there's enough
peripheral magic to this episode to sell
the more fun and she
like when she names him superman like
those little things that are just more
like nods to the audience and stuff like
that
i feel like for as bleak as this episode
does
get those moments of levity still
ring yeah to the point where you can
tell their intent but
i do think that objectively speaking you
do at least need to acknowledge it
because yeah it's something in the tone
where
it doesn't dismantle the emotionality of
the episode or what it's trying to
achieve to me
because it's not really the point that
stuff but yeah i can't deny like
especially if lois's character is built
on being shrewd and observant and
discerning
yeah you know it seems like it would be
her job to be able to see through her
disguise like that
but i love the office romance it
develops between them
it pulls you back into this moment where
we've already watched so many episodes
and then even if you
didn't start with these portrayals of
them
and you start like from this show but
you start with them on the other dc
shows you've seen so much of them
together at this point
and yet to go back to that moment like
especially when he's like i don't really
want to work with anyone else i'm okay
working with you
yeah i don't want to need my own beat i
loved it and i was
so endeared to it and it's it's it is
it puts you in the moment because this
the writing is so good and the
performances are so good and there's
still some
gre it almost did like the superman
origins
that in a in like a like a 20-minute
version
you know yeah yeah that's essentially
what it was
and i think though what what helps it uh
especially is as this episode is
unveiling through
the revelation that uh you know morgan
edge has infiltrated his mind
he's he's visiting all the things that
he holds most dear
all his like most blissful memories and
what and family and why that's all
important
uh to him then the stuff
that i was kind of questioning in the
beginning beginning of because
at first i was going why are we watching
this but then as it went i was like okay
i get why we're watching it and then i
really
loved it when you go to morgan edge at
the end where you
see him as a kid and he starts up his
fortress of solitude
up in the desert you're like man this
guy just had the the dark version of
everything this guy went
exactly engineered to be the polar
opposite yes
yeah and that made for a really nice
bookend to the episode too to come back
to them both
as youths and to pay off the device
of getting able to revisit so many
beautiful moments but as also a
fact-finding mission for morgan edge and
yeah just seeing
the the contrast and i love that they
still continue to play
him just as the product of his father's
upbringing and
his greeting on earth and all those
things like they even though
you know we are seeing a deep dive into
superman's history and we've only gotten
a little bit
of you know details spread out about
morgan edge's history i think they've
done a really nice draw
job making them a yin and yang that way
and also too i mean like even though
he's not like fully there you know it
seems like a pretty big blow to like
lose
jorel and lose i mean i'm sure the
fortress itself is salvageable but
i don't know i mean nobody ever truly
dies but it makes me wonder
like you know is is superman now just
gonna be without his
you know one place to retreat to or at
least his
you know guidance when all other options
are exhausted you know
well he was still partially raised by
it's easy for us as the audience to go
your hologram uh but it's still
like a spirit it's almost as if like a.i
come to life in a way you've still got
the spirit and the mind
you got the mind and the soul put into
this program essentially
so he was raised there at the fortress
of solitude
and you get to feel that and live in it
so
that way um the heartbreak is even more
felt like it's not just a
source of information of where he's gone
to like this he's got he had two dads
and he not just a biological dad an
adoptive dad he had
he really had the feeling of having two
fathers and yeah to have that moment
there at the end
was heartbreaking i was a little bit
confused how morgan edge
got there you just track him that's what
he said yeah it's like because you're
weak upon you know
uh dealing with the the eradicator in
the last episode yeah i followed you
here and i took advantage of your being
uh
juiced out again needing to recharge to
did he follow him there i thought he
didn't the last episode end where he
goes not all hope is lost and he's
looking upon
where his fortress of solitude is and
but you see
clark retreat to his so i don't know
either way he tracked him down and found
him and did stuff on her either way he
decided to go there
technical about it uh yeah
because it i like the way the origin
worked here even though it was
like going through it quickly because of
the fact that you know it's
when you learn that it's in a dream and
that turns into
a living nightmare eventually was
very effective and then going to morgan
edge
what i especially loved about his
portrayal
because you know take even man of steel
with uh which is a movie i love but take
man of steel with
a general zod and and cal
you know it's it's like brother just but
it's kind of it seems like a thing
they're saying
ceremonial more than anything they're
kryptonians yeah yeah they're going to
the formality yeah exactly you know and
yes we're part of the same race so we
need each other
this really showcased morgan edge's
insane
uh desperation for connection yeah yeah
and his like real
commitment and belief in this that he is
on the right track and that he needs
clark and that clark has abandoned them
and everything
yeah because it's more than just a plan
that he was set here for he wants
he he's he wants love the more his
family's back
morgan edge is a he's a baby i'm not
forgetting his actual kryptonian name at
the moment i'm sorry guys
um do you remember you know right now
i'm forgetting it off hand
this is something something rather is a
czar tell
i'm forgetting it at the moment uh yeah
like when you go to morgan edge
um we were talking oh yeah with this
with his father right there
you just in the first few sentences of
his father talking you're like oh okay
i get this guy you're like one of those
[ __ ] in lord of the rings
yeah who's just gonna abuse your kid
into being a worse version of you
congratulations yeah it turned you'd be
like
you don't need anyone well his father
points out right away
how yeah that's your weakness man you
want freaking family
you want companionship you should be
alone and you should have
pain damn it bro let's train you
to be a an evil dog in this fight and so
it
is actually if it would have been
effective even if you didn't have any of
those flashbacks and stuff
it would have been effective but because
but for
the story they had to tell for this
episode for that moment to really hit
where he has to go
make the hard decision of i have to
succumb and bend the knee
to morgan edge it hits that much harder
because you spent so much time in the
origins
of the love and now you have to see the
loss and the sacrifice and just
it's like we know how much this all
means to him but but
i thought it was clever device to really
put the
audience in the position of feeling this
ripped away from you
yeah and and experiencing the beginnings
of it
makes it that much of more of an impact
so yeah kudos to this episode because
this [ __ ] is so bleak and
so dark and i was just
i i i it because of my love for the show
it felt like i was in a nightmare
yeah well and they built that motif
really well
because at first when he's taken down
the guy with the metal mask and the
flamethrower and the street and there's
that
one figure yeah and it's like it's
it's enough that you're like well that's
something but at least for me my
experience watching it i
had forgotten about it when they get
into the delivery room and then all of a
sudden time starts to glitch and it
becomes very clear something's wrong and
and that at first when that happened i
was like did the
did the episode glitch or something did
it like jump forward like it was a truly
jarring moment that came for me really
out of nowhere and i thought they
built that like i said nicely over the
episode and paid it off well
to the point where yeah it's like you do
feel
this wonderful dream becomes such a sour
nightmare and it's funny because it's
it's the second comic
based show i have watched this week to
use this motif of we're going to start
out
in a flashback and we're going to carry
that sort of forward through time and
then in the last
quarter of the episode we're going to be
right back in the immediate stakes we
left off in last time
and uh you know you can't use that all
the time but i think it is really
effective when
put in the right place and i think this
is the right place too because you know
we're 10 episodes in
and it's a show where it's like we
already know the origin so it feels like
they really thought of
when is the most effective and the most
uh character
relevant time to bring that back in and
to kind of offset like you know the end
of the last episode was so intense and
it's
just it's this big action moment uh and
then
you know you start this one off in a
totally different place for a long time
and you go to the complete opposite end
of the emotional spectrum
and you remind yourself sort of halfway
through or you know two-thirds of the
way through the season of just
what the stakes are and how hard this
all is and it's one of those things
where you feel their bargain of you know
like we
we're going to start a family we could
do this but also
it's it's that bargain of like when you
have the prospect in your hand of like
we're pregnant we didn't know this is
possible well we'll make it work and
then down the line you see
well we'll make it work sometimes is not
actually all that viable
or is much messier than just yeah we'll
make it work and right now i mean
i can't imagine that lois or jonathan or
jordan are going to die
but you know it certainly feels like a
legitimate
palpable tension for them and her going
to call john irons at the end of the
episode like
that was one of those things too where i
was like okay yeah like you're not
dramatically wasting any time you know
it's it's a harsh moment but it's also
like
i guess yeah like lois being the shrewd
operator that she is
has to know that well at this point you
know the writing's on the wall and it's
great because it's like we've had this
whole time to go yeah he's not going to
defect from his
earth family to the kryptonian family
unless there's some kind of leverage
brought into place like they do here so
yeah i thought you know
it was really nicely done from a
dramatic perspective
in justifying all those warm tones and
then crushing them as well
yeah yeah it's really yeah like
beautifully done
that was man that was a harrowing one
it's not a feeling you you like you
don't leave this feeling good but
oh yeah i i i admire the craft
some really solid writing yeah
like and it's nice in an episode like
this to have the little nitpicks
like oh you know the glasses thing like
that's not you know
what it's about when i feel like all the
stuff that it is about you know really
does
fire on all cylinders oh yeah well i
mean in those flash
like that shot when perry white's like
this isn't a track and then you just see
superman flying
yeah i'm like what a great great shot
what an amazing shot uh-huh
they could have done that in freaking
the 2000s superman returns like that
shot easily they could have
absolutely been like well has no one
never thought of that shot it's
wonderful yeah
i thought of that moment and then damn
yeah yeah well that's the other thing
too is they they're really good at
capturing superman on this show and like
even though
even the running thing at the beginning
and transitioning not only smoothly
uh warping from young clark into adult
clark but just that
you know like the way they've been able
to realize his powers and also make
things that might have been clowned on
before seem like yeah real handy and
cool like this show makes ice breath
looks so much cooler than i've ever seen
it before
well every punch has that like sonic
boom yeah yeah that's a vibrational
energy
yeah there's always like a a camera
emphasis with every punch physically on
screen
when morgan edge and cal are fighting
like literally when he punches clark
there's a
boom yeah yeah too yeah yeah the actual
like sonic wave
yes sonic boom i don't know i'm not
trying to like clarify i'm
just like yes okay so not a camera
motion but a visual effect also that too
yes
yeah i love it man it's uh
because i admire the i do admire the
craft a lot of
it's kind of like this you know some
people are like we don't need to see
batman's origin again
we don't need to see his parents get
killed again come on yeah people feel
that way
and for me that's how i started off with
this
we don't need to see batman's orchid
again and then they managed to hook me
into it
in a way that felt fresh yeah that's why
and that's
basically my encompassing thought on it
is i didn't
i wasn't super down to really
live in this and while i was enjoying it
i'm like ah come on let's get back to
the interesting
crazy plot that's going on right now
yeah yeah uh
i it kept reeling me in really me and to
just freaking just grab my heart and
cuddled me
it's right to their honeymooning kids
and then destroyed me yeah just like
shoved you down a flight of stairs after
that
damn that is effective
it is effective yeah and it's hateable
too and i love that more like morgan
edge has become
so much better of a character than i
would have thought at the outset
well it's it i i like it more because
morgan edges
the what morgan edge felt like was this
cliche
american businessman shark
he felt like i was like uh we're gonna
do like commentary political commentary
that i've probably seen a thousand times
by this point we're going to do another
supernatural dick roman
yes or uh freaking um
uh maxwell lord yeah we're gonna do
that again and we didn't and then
i respect it because i'm like okay it
makes sense why that personality feels
so
like typical and predictable and cliche
because that's the persona yeah
so it's okay that if that doesn't feel
real
yeah because when you get to know the
real him you're like damn you're pitiful
yeah yeah and yet i see how you chose
this track in life somehow
yeah yeah yeah they harmonize well like
he really views himself as
family to them yeah and that's what's so
effective about his performance that's
the
unnerving part when he's like um
uncle morgan's here or something yeah
you're like he really doesn't
think of yourself as their uncle don't
you yeah
yeah in a twisted way he's a family guy
he is he
that's all he wants and so yeah he's
just he's he's got this desperate need
for
for
connection and acceptance man and uh
i admire it just when i thought like we
were walking into an episode that i
might not be super into at the
at the outset a wheel spinner i was like
wow this really got me and gregory smith
is a hell of a director
uh he directed i i fell off the flash
around like season five but he's
directed a few episodes of these dc
shows
and um he directed one of my favorite
flash
episodes it's the one where like a bomb
goes off
and there's it and then like basically
he he gets
flash stays in the speed force for the
whole episode
because he has to figure out how to save
people
like how to prevent this situation from
the bomb because it's a nuclear bomb so
this bomb is just slowly exploding
slowly and he's like pulling different
people and he's trying to do like the
map
it's like super intense and wildly
executed with some experimental shots
i think it's it is one of the fan
favorites and it's a freaking
like even if you haven't seen the flash
i would be like just watch this one
episode you gotta watch this one episode
all right the craft on this episode is
phenomenal
and uh if you guys have seen you know
what i'm talking about and
yeah like just him being here i'm like
yeah man i forget you're like a really
good director you know gregory smith
yeah from small soldiers in seventh
heaven yes
who's gone on that is the seventh heaven
no wasn't he on a tv show john everwood
ever would there you go
46 cast members on seventh heaven and
you thought gregory smith
i did he looks he had that 90s he looks
like
a guy who looks like he looks like a guy
yeah
he looks like half the cast half the
cast of every show on
that prime time slot in those handful
years
all right guys well what did you think
about this episode did you enjoy it
quite as much as
us leave your thoughts down below wow
that really left me with a
hollow feeling subscribe click that bell
to watch us get more hollow hit that
like button and we'll catch you guys
soon